it's quarter to three there's no one in
the place except you and me make it one
for my baby one whole head job once I
was good at it
I know what do you want I want to ask
you some questions the story the fiends
this is stunning visual environments it
was a pleasure getting back to the world
of Blade Runner again
where we're going
[Music]
when I dress the original Bladerunner 35
years ago and could never the magical
iconic would still be
I have massive respect for the world the
Middle East got created
did runner revolutionize the we would
view science fiction when I heard that
Ridley was continuing the narrative I
was already invested I already wanted to
know what happened next I think it's
kind of fun to play a character thirty
years later used to trying on old
clothes happily they still fit from the
cinematography to the script to working
with Denis and Ridley Roger Harrison and
Ryan I just feel really lucky just to be
on the team
[Music]
I never felt that much pressure of my
shoulder thinking that we'd list that
with this movie I've never worked on a
film is firmly set from different
lighting patterns
technically cut shallow
they created this incredible world where
there was a living breathing universe
defining this was like walking on a
knife's edge riding the line between the
original film and what we're doing now
it's not just a replica of the first
film we're marrying the familiar with
slightly diverged in order to give
ourselves an identity we're trying to
keep the visual effects very reality
based and grounded people should look at
it go well it's a beautiful shot how did
they get it
I always told you Harry special
their story isn't over yet
this movie dissolves meta-study themself
that there's always more to tell that
two hours will allow we are making
something special
[Music]
it feels like a very grounded realistic
extension of the original it's good to
be home again
would you bring no one you know you're
here
this is impossible
[Music]
Oh
you